I recently flew all the way to Australia
for their annual croc trip as in
crocodile in case that wasn't clear to
research these living dinosaurs and they
released them back into the river it all
goes down on the Steve Irwin wildlife
reserve which we'll explain at the
outfit that I am wearing and talk to the
gang including 19 year old bindi and her
longtime boyfriend Chandler you posted a
certain picture with rings I know it was
international diamond day you didn't
have diamonds but the ring was
definitely on a very interesting finger
oh it's so funny diamonds were a little
bit out of our budget yeah I love it on
a budget so we decided to invest in our
ring pups and I think that if you can
eat your ring it's not really a real
engagement they've been together for
over two years traveled the world and
Vindi calls Chandler my love today
tomorrow always but will the 20 year old
wakeboarder make it official and pop the
question to bindi who's just 19 no not
yet no I'm the luckiest guy in the world
and one day I would be really blessed to
be able to but just ring pops and we're
just enjoying life right now eventuate
i'm sure they'll call you first I'm
gonna hold you to that
honestly we'll actually we'll give you a
call and it can be your exciting
exclusive hey Rox
Mindy's parents Terry and the late Steve
Irwin were married for 14 years
Terry's remained single since his death
contrary to some reports and one of the
main things that I think you have to
deflect as far as rumors go that about
relationships and rumors of Russell
Crowe the men in my life are good
friends and I'm very blessed for me I
felt like I got my happily ever after
I've had some very torrid magazine
affairs but they were only in magazines
you know one of the other things that
Terry said that I really kind of like
this point is that she wants to get out
there that you don't have to be in a
relationship to be happy
she is very happy right now as long as
she's happy that's all that matters
[Music]
you